this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
wednesday
the 13th of [__] july the joint
is brought to you by one of my favorites
liquid iv
listen the summer months are here it's
hot out there you gotta stay fueled and
hydrated one stick of liquid iv in 16
ounces of water hydrates you two times
faster and more efficiently than water
alone liquid iv products taste great
with 10 refreshing fake flavors you know
what mine are
grape the cherry the pina colada the
tropical punch and you know what else
they got kombucha
use liquid iv first thing in the morning
before a workout
when you feel run down after a long
night out
and to manage your daily hydration the
single serve packaging helps you stay
hydrated while you're on the go on the
road jumping up and down me i love
liquid iv i wake up a little bit in the
morning i'm out of it i drink my coffee
i take my shower right before the gym i
blast my liquid iv i put a couple drops
in there of uh
sell food and forget about it liquid iv
uses cellular transport technology
designed to enhance
rapid absorption of water do me a favor
grab your liquid iv in bulk
nationwide at costco or i'll tell you
what uncle joey's gonna do for you i'm
gonna get you 25
off
when you go to liquidity.com and use
code joey at checkout that's 25 off
anything you can order from liquid ib to
keep you hydrated
use promo code joey at liquidity.com
again
joey at liquidity.com i'm gonna save you
on liquid iv and you guys know these
[__] things are pricey so i'm hooking
you up on a wednesday morning the joint
is also brought to you by factor listen
summer is for relaxing not for grocery
shopping and cooking and doing dishes
fact that has tons of balance delicious
add-ons that will help you stay on track
all summer like smoothies shakes and
snacks let me tell you something those
smoothies are [__] delicious
facts factor makes it easy to eat well
for breakfast lunch and dinner and
anything in between
they're fresh never frozen and the meals
are delicious and nutritious you can
feel good all summer with calorie smart
and keto options excellently
proportioned to keep you on track with
your goals
factor off is 32 meals per week
including
11 keto options new gourmet plus meals
make eating at home feel like you're in
a [__] chef's house you understand me
don't spend your after work hours in a
grocery store in the kitchen
let factor deliver ready-made meals
right to your door each factor meal
arrives and prepared by their team of
chefs ready to eat
in two minutes they offer vegan veggie
meals
keto meals calorie smart meals
cold pressed juices smoothies energy
bites
they're going to keep you fueled and
focused all day but it starts with you
go to dot factor 75.com
joey120 again
dot factor75.com
joey120 to get you 120 off your first
order go to dot factor 75 dot com slash
joey for a hundred and
120 for 120 off again
dot factor 75.com
joey120
the joint is also brought to you by when
it comes to cbd they're the best how do
i know
because they've been here for me for
five years and i won't even think of
going anywhere else
cbd lion do me a favor go to the cbd
lion right now
and read the third party lab results if
there's something you like
order it press encode joey joint or
church and get 20 off delivered to your
house they also have a tremendous delta
eight [__]
gummy that'll put you through [__]
the stratosphere and i'm gonna save you
20 right now so it's a [__] bargain
go to cbdlion.com read the third party
lab results
put in joint joey or church and get 20
off and now let's get this [__]
party started
[Music]
welcome to uncle joey's joint
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday july the 13th
i can't [__] believe it's july as a
matter of fact today's two year
anniversary
from when i heard on television that
there was gonna be no school in
california and i told my wife we're out
of here
today's the two-year [__] anniversary
of us going [__] california we're going
back to new jersey it's a beautiful day
to be alive
uh i got a couple emails about this
week's podcast already people are pissed
off at me that i
told you that brian piccolo died in the
[__] movie i mean listen i'm the type
of guy if a movie's out five years
and if you're a real [__] you've
already seen the [__] after five years
i'm talking about the [__] movie
there's no spoiler alerts but my nephew
called me up this morning he's like hey
[__]
why'd you tell me that [__] james
khan died in the movie i wanted to watch
it i don't know it's 50 [__] that movie
came out 50 [__] years ago that movie
came out when i was in the third grade
at sacred heart school for boys we
watched on a sunday night and who the
[__] what was that 1971
brian's song
abc movie of the [__] week
71 that means it's been yeah about 50
[__] years 80 90 2000 2011
2000 what the [__] people so it doesn't
matter
you know
that's one thing that i really [__]
miss like
i'm an old man as you can tell i got
white [__] eyebrows you know once you
got white [__] eyebrows you're a
[__] old man all right
you know i could sit there and pick them
one by one you don't have no [__]
idea how much that hurts that's like
being a pow in vietnam they just pick
your [__] eyebrows at my age
especially the white ones which you get
old [__] you try to trim your
nose hairs even the [__] uh manscape
manscape is tremendous the [__] nose
thing but i gotta tell you something
when you talk when you're dealing with
white hairs it's over even on my dick my
[__] when you're trying to shave
whitehead like this times i'm manscaping
my dick sack and i'm like that it's
working perfectly almost like this is
like a [__] thing and it's because it
hit a white hair like those white hairs
are [__] brutal but anyway who gives
a [__] about white hairs you know what's
crazy that out of all like when you get
older
you know and i tell you people this all
the time i don't want to sound like that
guy like back in my day no not back in
anybody's day because this was back i
still remember this 15 years ago i said
something on monday's podcast and a
couple people hit me and i felt good
that
i said those words you know people tell
me all the time i just didn't make this
up that they go to the movies and they
left and they don't even know what
happened like the movie went by [__]
fast you know
and it felt like that overcovered
like it really felt like that the movies
weren't clicking like the sons of the
many saints in newark they just didn't
click
for you you went to the movies you saw a
movie you left
yes it bothers the [__] out of me
because out of all my [__] things i
talk about drugs cocaine
you know eating ass all these [__]
stupid things you do as a man i think
the most rewarding the favorite thing in
my life
and i'm gonna tell you how much i loved
it
i think out of all the things i did
my escape
because i i wanted to think about this
before i brought this podcast up to you
guys
you know guys we all have an escape we
don't we don't realize it while you're
doing it but years later you'll realize
that for some people it's doing drugs
like myself
you know i'm a [__] dummy for some
people it's just strumming the chords on
a guitar
you know they go in a room and put music
on and just drum the chords on a guitar
they don't want to join a band they
don't want to do any of that [__]
you know when you go out and drink let's
say you had a you work a nine to five
and you work all [__] week and you
drink and after work you guys do uh
happy hours and [__] that's your escape
you know like a couple cocktails with
your friends your girlfriend meets you
that's your escape from the week you
know that's it you're done with work you
don't want to hear about computers you
don't want to hear about [__] dildos
that god didn't get shipped you don't
want to you know you just don't want to
hear that [__] no more it's time to
[__] relax and tune away and that's
great it's like when we go on vacation
with a loved one when you go on vacation
with your family and you put your feet
up at the beach like snoop dogg in that
[__] corona commercial you know
that's relaxation that's escaping you
know escaping what joey what are you
escaping yeah reality my brother george
when he went to rehab he became a
[__] uh like a [__] therapist he's
not a therapist but when he first went
to rehab and got out in like 93. you
know he was you know those people were
clean for like a month and a half and
then that month and a half they tell
everybody how they should run their
[__] life you know
i remember one day i was smoking pot and
he came out he's like hey man you got to
stop smoking pot i'm like why he goes
because you're escaping reality
and i'm like i know
that's what i want to do
i hate my [__] life along like
everybody else i'm broke i [__] don't
have a career you know this is when you
escape yourself but way before that
like way before that escape happened my
escape was
the [__] movie theaters
i
dog and i started that escape when i was
like five
when i was like five my godfather took
me to a couple of those kid movies and
he's like dog i can't do these no more
i can't do another love bug or another
[__] uh the world's strongest man
with jan michael vincent i can't do
these no more
if you go to movies you got to do adult
movies and i was like okay if that's
what it takes you know and so by the
time i was five six i was already
watching like change bomb movies all
that the velocity papers i saw that
that's the first movie i saw in times
square the [__] velocity papers with
charles bronson when he played a rat i
didn't i was huh
yeah i wasn't too happy with that [__]
charles bronson being a rat didn't
[__] sit well with uncle joey but
what am i gonna do
and i think it was like maybe
like you go to the movies with parents
or got parents or
you know your friends and family a
family member like i love the [__]
movies i love snoopy
i loved all that [__] my first
girlfriend was a chinese girl on 88th
street we were like six
and her father worked for [__] the
schultz
but the guy that does snoopy yeah bro
who the [__] you think you're dealing
with and
this girl used to take me and all the
little chinese girlfriends and little
puerto rican kids like 10 of us would go
to movie theater when there was nobody
in the movie theater they would make
popcorn for us and we'd watch [__]
charlie brown on the upper west side
like [__] doctors as a kid like eight
[__] years old we're already doing
this [__]
so
i don't know i don't know when the first
time i just started
and then when i moved to jersey guys
like when i was 11
me and my [__] goomba started taking
buses from kennedy boulevard
38th street all the way down to journal
square and they had those one two
three movie theaters when we were kids
there was one like deep into general
square but there was one right on
kennedy boulevard
guys i saw all the pink panthers there i
saw richard pryor live on the sunset
strip there
i saw a [__] kentucky fried movie
there we are from another planet
we will not harm you all this [__] in
here
that's a great scene in the movie if
you've never seen the kentucky pride
movie the kentucky fried movie and uh
there was another one groove tube those
two were the first movies that got me
[__] going about comedy i think they
were done like by uh
the canadian improv group
like i didn't know it at the [__]
time but when i grew older i went to
revisit one of those movies
and it was like all those people from
like uh
yeah yeah it was pretty interesting [__]
uh
but the scene i remember the most is
they're in a courtroom and the guy takes
out a [__] dildo puts it on his head
and he's the attorney or somebody starts
telling the guy we are from another
planet we will not harm you with a dick
on his head me and my little [__]
idiot buddies lost it giggling like
little [__]
but i love that like our saturdays were
about the [__] movies
by the time i was nine
that was it i was going to movies by
myself and [__] i would tell my mom mom
i'm going and in union city we had the
cinema
which was my [__] honorary movie
theater on 48th and burning line avenue
we had cena tony the cuban theater on
[__] 13th and new york avenue down
there not even new york avenue we had
the mayfair theater in west new york
that was [__] tremendous we had the
edgewater theater right on the [__]
water there but my main [__]
movie theater was the cinema guys
there was no reefer then there was no
alcohol
that union city cinema it was like a
[__] for me going to the movies was
like an event
i mean i made it into a [__] event
for years
and i'm going to prove it to you
[__] i still remember going to
see the longest yard original
rocky
uh
you know
[__] uh the exorcist we all would go
up there on saturdays like 10 [__]
kids i still remember jumping up and
down in the [__] longest yard the
original
on our seats clapping for the mean
machine and on the walk home feeling bad
because i was a catholic and i was
cheering for [__] convicts like i was
like what am i doing i'm cheering for
[__] convicts you know like i heard
that that was my mindset like although
like i still remember being in rocky and
the [__] whole movie theater was on
their feet just chanting rocky rocky and
us as kids just going [__] crazy like
that was my world when i watch those
bruce lee movies at night here down here
sometimes
i cry like when i watch chinese
connection i cry it's painful to watch
because i remember
like how much fun we had before and
after that movie anytime we went to the
union city cinema we always caught the
first you know like the first showing
like right after [__] school like
when a movie came out on a friday we'd
be there like friday or saturday morning
but then for the second
and third review i would go late night
with my buddies like i would tell my mom
i'm going to the 10 30 [__] movie at
the cinema i was a kid
and she would let me
pino mike the [__] [__] his father
was a superintendent in our building not
my building but penile's building and
they called him mike the rethought he
was a sweetheart of a kid we [__] go
up we'd walk up bergen line and we'll
get like [__] ice cream and [__]
go to the movie theater get popcorn
cause [__] havoc in there then on the
way home we loved it because ponte corvo
deli on 32nd and bergen line would leave
all their fruit boxes out and meme
[__] mike and pino would beat the
[__] out of those boxes i know joey why
would you beat up a box because you're
11 and you're a [__] idiot that's why
so we beat up the boxes we kick them all
into burger lane avenue and that was the
end of that then my mom died
and we were still i was more of a movie
buff than ever
because i would just disappear into
movie theaters you know like if i was
feeling down i'd just go see a movie and
the movie would be playing but i'd just
be in there thinking like it was my
church for a long time a movie theater
was my [__] church
and once i started getting high
like 16 and 17
by the time i was 21
i was going to the movies by myself as
pathetic as that was from the ages of
maybe
17 to maybe
25 i saw i don't know how many movies
i saw some with people but
guys 90 of the time and i wanted
i watched them by myself why because i
didn't want to [__] hear nobody's
[__] i didn't want to hear nobody's
[__] about being tired or being cold
or you know when people move around it
bothers the [__] out of me even when i
did coke like if i was doing coke with
mike and there'd be girls here walking
around they tell them shut the [__] down
enough with the walking around you're
just allowed to get up to pee that's it
no more walking around what's all this
[__] walking so it distracts the [__]
out of me right when i'm watching a
movie and [__]
so i i just found this thing to go to
the movies by myself and i had a whole
[__]
when i lived in cliffside park with
george
in 84 85
83 i would just my whole thing i would
go to the [__] chinese restaurant
the 11 o'clock
seating like i'd be there because i
wanted to go to 11 30 movie
you follow me so i didn't want to [__]
around
so i would [__] go to 11 o'clock
chinese food i get the same thing every
time szechuan beef
steamed rice and allegro
that's my pre-movie [__] ritual
that's how it works now
you smoke a joint on the way to the
chinese restaurant
and after you eat chinese food it's a
[__] definite there's the after
dinner joint you understand me the after
the aperitif
and you're going in there before the
movie so it was perfect so we smoke a
half a doob
before the chinese food and then when
you get out of chinese food you smoke
the full [__] number and by the time
you walk in the movie theater your
[__] lights out you understand me
and
i did that for years by myself i could
tell you
on three hands how many [__] movies i
went to myself from american gigolo to
rambo
part two to [__]
desperately seeking susan all those
movies i found
i found my [__] like my utopia going
to a movie by myself and just putting
the feet up now it was a different
schedule if i went to harlem
now if i went to a movie in jersey i
would get chinese food but if i want the
movie in harlem
we'd stop at the cuban joint you
understand me so i'd take the bus over
to 178
i'd go to that enchanted lily in
cliffside and i'd take the [__] bus
or i'd walk over to george washington
bridge get to 178th street walk to
amsterdam get a [__] dime bag
roll it and smoke a joint on the way i
would go to 176th street on the corner
there
and i get cuban [__] lunch bolichi
white rice fried bananas black beans
coco rico i do the whole [__] thing
that's a puerto rican soda coco rico and
then i walk to 181st street
oh my god it's [__] delicious
i go to 181st street in broadway and
there was a movie theater they had going
there and that was the black movie
theater
that's if i wanted action
like if i wanted to really [__] laugh
i went to the black movie theater
rambo
you know i went to all those movies up
there
if i was broke and i just wanted to be
alone i didn't want to giggle i would go
to there was a movie theater
about three blocks down on 81st street
it was like two movies for five dollars
those type of things in the afternoon
like i'd go see american gigolo and fifa
hearts with stephen bauer
i'd go see like [__] you know
death wish one and death wish two all
that type of [__] you know
guys for me it was just like uh
it's like some people like going to con
and walking around with a [__] tuxedo
hahaha what'd you think of the movie oh
the underlying ambition of the character
go [__] yourself i didn't that's not me
i just went there as a ritual it was my
it was my escape looking back on it
it was my escape from even drugs
like i had an escape from the escape
like most people get high they gotta
escape uncle joey had it taken a deep
further i hadn't escaped from my escape
you know and i would go to those movies
and i would
look at the characters and i would
[__] daydream you know like i would
go someday i'll be in a movie
and then i go come on joey you're never
going to be in a [__] movie
or whatever one day i don't know it was
just i loved the cinema i loved
everything about it i could care less
what was going on in the world as long
as i had a movie to go watch
you know like i i [__] loved
everything about it even today like i i
love smoking a [__] joint you know
what like you can't watch any movies now
but if i see something old is coming on
like i still remember going to see angel
heart and the movie to mickey
at rook
at the there's the fox theater in
boulder but up the corner there's a
little movie theater next to the deli
zone in boulder that's where it used to
be up on the hill
before the delhi zone was there i used
to go to that movie theater all the time
by myself i saw i remember i went to see
the year the dragon by myself in 1985 at
the fox theater
and after about 20 minutes i walked out
of that [__] i'm like [__]
mickey rourke acting like a [__]
gangster as a cop [__] that punk and i
walked out i went to see it a couple
weeks later i understood where it was
coming from
but those were the movies i used to go
see [__]
yeah the dragon i still remember going
to see angel heart up the corner from
that movie theater
getting [__] so stoned and being
scared in there
and uh
i didn't know what the [__] movie the
movie was great but
i'm like what the [__] just happened and
staying in there for the [__] neck
showing like the people coming up to me
going you know you have to leave i'm not
going anywhere
well you have to pay again i'm not
paying again because i didn't see it the
first time i sat here i didn't know what
the [__] was going on and the guy's like
that happens to a lot of people with
this [__] movie i swear to god i
thought that was my life that was
i don't even know how to [__]
describe that's why when i started doing
movies
it felt so much
better
like it felt good but i couldn't explain
it to anybody i never explained to
anybody until now for the first time
why i enjoyed working on movies so much
because they were everything to me
when you're an immigrant
or at least in my situation i think
cinema
teaches you
i mean for me it really you know i was
catching all those movies as a young kid
i've never i don't ever remember getting
formal training in english
like i don't remember somebody sitting
me down and going okay we're gonna start
from scratch today
like when i was three four or five i
remember just going to school and
knowing what everybody else knew and i
knew that my mother the only thing my
mother requested for me was not to speak
with an accent
she felt that if i talked with an
accident i was going to get beat up on
or
goofed on so she's like we're going to
eliminate that [__] spanish accent
so i i don't know i think i did it all
with cinema taught me how to live
as stupid as it sounds cinema taught me
how to act sometimes cena
you know it's funny like the first time
i went on a on a set like the first time
you go on a set i understand you're a
little scared you don't know what's
going on but once they say action camera
whatever the [__]
lights action camera
you know
i'm doing what i saw other people do
throughout the years i wasn't doing
nothing spectacular i'm not a great
[__] actor i just did what other
people did i i copied them you know when
i walk i don't even know what good
acting was like i didn't know i went to
all these movies and i didn't know what
good acting was until maybe i was like
and i started painting i listened to all
these [__] street people oh he's a
great actor what the [__] do you know
who are you shakespeare
i don't know when people say that [__]
to me it drives me crazy like regular
civilians like he's such a great actor
so i would watch these movies and go i
don't even know if these people are
talking about acting
my point is that there was times that i
was on a movie set that there were
people there like actors
and like the director would have to go
up to them and say something
and i would go
that [__] is never going to say
that to me because i already knew that
like do you know what i mean like how
did i learn that i learned that from
watching
[__] 8 000 movies i mean i am the
[__] king
you know i was goofing on those people
the other day but i just want to tell
you and this is why i'm explaining
myself because i am the king of [__]
worthless information
i'm the king
you know you knowing that paul diana was
the first singer
of iron maiden
yeah unless i go on jeopardy and they
pop that question you don't need that
knowledge for anything else you know
when you uh yeah you know when when when
when you know and i'm not putting
anybody down i'm just explaining to you
that yeah
listen right now 20 [__] 40 years ago
people would tell me hey
your brain's going to rot from [__]
smoking pot
right people always said to you you're
[__] up from smoking pop [__]
now i'm making money from smoking pot
right i got this weed company and i'm
making money from it so
that was one of the worthless
informations that i
gathered but it came to pay off 40 years
later who knew that we was going to be
legal and we're going to be smoking and
tremendous comes out july 16th
that's the last chamber that's the last
chapter in the laughing gas
[__] thing well i remember july 16th
which makes it boom
saturday
stop at the ice cream shop it's going to
be exclusive at the ice cream shop for
maybe a week
then it gets shipped out to other
[__] stores in california and
anywhere else do not forget laughing gas
is also at buddies bodega and the
[__] bronx i'll be going up
there in a few weeks
my friend brought me some reefer from a
different [__] uh
she works at a dispensary in the bronx
and she brought me some 30 reefer from
it
not bad
i'm not bad it was [__] pricey she
told me what she paid and i was like wow
but it wasn't bad it's not what i got
it's not what uncle joey gets but it'll
[__] work
but anyway
most i still remember being like
in baseball
like in baseball
i didn't want to [__] up but i knew what
i was doing
the only thing i didn't know what that
what they were talking about when they
were on your marks i i'm like what am i
running a race i didn't know what the
[__] when they say on your marks it's
your starting position like
everybody on their mark and yeah you're
gonna walk towards mike and shake his
hand but for right now you're starting
right there when they would say on your
marks i'd be [__] walking around like
like [__] what they saying but after
they corrected me on that i was pretty
good and then the rest of the [__] i
just put together an acting class
but when i did basketball
listen when i did basketball there was
no acting training
there was no nothing it was just from
what i watched on television all those
years of watching tv so
who knows what
wasted information
who knows
so nothing is really wasted when you
read a book or when you read about weed
because you don't know when this is
going to get popular so for all those
years i read about marijuana i smoked it
i [__] learned about it i learned how
to roll joints i learned how it grew you
know all this [__] but i was never going
to do anything with it but now
people take my word for what's good
wheat i like good weed i've been smoking
it for 40 [__] years i'm 59 i've been
smoking weed for 45 [__] years you
know i know good weed i've seen the
evolution on it but anyway who gives a
[__] about the reefer
it was a big part of me going to the
movie theater smoking a nice [__]
joint to absorb the [__] movie
but i can't describe how much a piece i
was
and now you go to a movie theater
the experience
sucks
it sucks it really does suck
you know you you [__] overpay
then you go and then you get [__]
rape for [__] sodas seven dollars for
a soda that soda costs 20 cents
i didn't know the situation with movie
theaters was how it was until i tried to
get a movie to do a screening of the
many saints in newark and then people
were telling me what like what the costs
were like
i don't i don't think studios pay movie
theaters to show their movies
the only profit they make is at the
[__] concession stance
so you know
it just sucks i
when i was talking to my nephew this
morning
i don't have a lot of [__] uh bucket
list [__]
you know but there is one thing i'd
really like to do
for me it would be in the words of rudy
sajo will be a labor of love i would
love to open up a movie theater
not big
99 seats it would not be for profit
if i broke even doing it i would be
ecstatic
because
i would you know i guess i would have to
get the format of
the movie theaters and not make any
money at the door but i'll tell you what
i would do i [__] went to a movie
theater by myself
in 1985 in san francisco to see the
movie mask
with cher and another [__] dude great
movie chef [__] stole the movie
this place blew me the [__] apart this
movie theater was on hate ashbury
i think it was 85 at the time
i think the regular prices to go see a
movie were like seven bucks
six bucks
i tell you they wanted ten
i'm gonna tell you why
first of all it sat like 90 people
you did not sit in chairs you sat on
couches
which i thought was brilliant
they had three man couches and two man
couches throughout the whole thing
with a little table up front you could
put your feet on and on the side they
had a little table
where you could put your sodas and your
[__] popcorns let me tell you what
these [__] had when you walked
in
i'll never forget this it made such an
impression on me that this has always
been one of my dreams i just didn't know
where the [__] this started hopefully if
one of you people know we get together
and do this this is a bunch of abandoned
little movie theaters a bunch
a bunch of them
drive-ins there's tons of [__]
drive-ins there's abandon
it would be now if you go to driving
have you anybody seen the new
state-of-the-art driving i just saw like
one that's opening and [__] michigan
or some [__]
[__] gorgeous gorgeous you know you
don't even put the it connects to your
phone now the bluetooth the movie
theater you have to put a box on your
[__] window anyway
this is my [__] dream so
i went into this movie theater and i'll
never forget that i saw the chick as i
walked in
i saw the chick
she had those butter four packs of
butter
as i walked in i got on the line there
was maybe three people on the line you
know and she unpacked one of the sticks
of butter and put them on the [__]
thing on this little melter and she was
putting popcorn through there it was
real [__] butter oh my god and then
she put salt on it for you like she took
half like the real way you said you ever
go to movie theater now the guy just
fills it up and then you have to fill it
in with that [__] artificial
diabetic butter that tastes like [__]
and your hands get all greasy and [__]
[__] that
this lady [__] put half in she put
salt and pepper in a little bit of
butter and then she put more popcorn
then she put the butter and then more
popcorn
it was done [__] correctly the other
chick next to her was making fresh
chocolate chip cookies not the [__]
thing with the knife where you put it
and it blows up into a hershey cookie no
this [__] had the batter and you went
up there and said how many cookies you
want you tell her 12. and she make
either little ones or three big ones or
something for two bucks or something she
put them in the oven and then you you
waited 10 minutes or whatever the [__]
they had
neat stuff in there they had like
you know with san francisco so there's
always got to be a veggie dish
you know like there was something like
sprouts or something like that it wasn't
there was no hot dogs there was nothing
like that i was just popcorn i think
they had ice cream
they had real sodas in a can and [__]
like that they sold beer
you know they had a liquor license or
maybe they didn't have a liquor license
it didn't matter they made like they had
those little pina coladas that you could
drink in there and a little more guys
it was one of the most enjoy i didn't
drink i just went up there put my feet
up and i watched [__] mask eating
popcorn and i must have devoured a ton
of those chocolate chip cookies and they
gave you milk
it was milk and cookies to watch that's
what you want in a [__] movie theater
i don't want a [__] hot dog at a
movie theater with this yankee game
i want to sit back you know when you're
home do you go to a movie theater i need
to [__] when you're home watching a
movie
do you eat a [__] hot dog then why
the [__] would you watch in the movie
theater do you understand what i'm
saying here when you're home what would
you like to [__] watch a movie with
nice piece of [__] pound cake
a nice apple pie a la mode with
haagen-dazs vanilla ice cream on that
dutch apple
you know what i'm saying i have a
smoking room in the back
for discussions and chats
we could have a thing up front for q and
a's maybe sit 90 people and just open up
friday and saturday for special events
and maybe
during the week for a matinee that would
that would make my
that would make my dick so hard guys
guys i'm the type of guy if i if i like
a movie i'll watch the movie three or
four times
that's on a minimum i'll watch a movie
three four times and that's just on a
[__] minimum okay
so for you people that are watching this
that's what they took away from us over
the years i mean a lot of things have
changed
but for me that's what i wanted to talk
about the other day listen movies are
okay i didn't want to insult nobody or
insult anybody's
film work or anything like that but
you know when you went to see the pope
of greenwich village
you left there and you at least you gave
me three lines from that we need a fancy
suit for you got no job to wear it you
know oh go home and get your [__]
shine box you know
that's a memorable [__] line you know
what i'm saying like all these movies
gave you
you know uh what's the movie with the
[__] bowling and all that [__] with
the guy had woody harrelson and
and all those guys
and the dude think of that movie i'm not
trying to put anything down i'm just
throwing your favorite movies on you
okay
the godfather
hangover you know there's been so many
great movies now
the last five years
which one of those movies can you hit me
with this [__] scumbag whoa avatar
yeah but listen guy you're blowing 500
million dollars on that
you know that better be [__] good
that better be a [__] good movie
because you're blowing
500 million [__] dollars on that so
before you walk around with your ego
james cameron all this movie you spent
500 million dollars in four [__]
years
okay so and the last avatar i don't even
remember it i don't even know what the
[__] line from the movie was so do
you understand why i'm talking to the
godfather
leave the gun take the cannolis
there's lines
you know there's lines
none of these movies and listen man i
was a spider-man too and i had a great
time it was great working with sam raimi
i really enjoyed it but i was always mad
at myself for doing that movie
i needed the money you know what i'm
saying like the money at that point was
necessary
but i was always mad about doing that
movie even though i had a great time the
movie was a great experience we got some
jokes if you ain't high by two o'clock
go [__] your mother you know all that
[__] came from that movie
but it was the beginning of
these movies they're making now i don't
even know what the [__] they're doing
you know i i dear dad watch that
commercial for thor
you know it looks [__] like they
didn't shoot a scene
everything is cgi or whatever the [__]
that is i don't want to watch one of
those [__] once i see cgi
really you like it
[Music]
look at guys whether it's podcast or
stand-up or movies i like my [__] to be
serious
i want to get something out of this
[__] movie
i want to get with the i want to get the
message that the writer's trying to get
across i don't care about the characters
and the growth of the characters or the
arc that doesn't matter to me
that doesn't matter to me guys i could
lie to you and tell you oh the ark of
the guy that that does that's never
mattered to me you know that's [__]
that's chit-chat you know people trying
to be [__] smarter than what the [__]
they are
but i like to get what the director or
the writer was trying to get out of this
[__] movie what's the message
you know and then we go back to somebody
like james khan
you know
in 19 [__]
79 my mom passed and by 1980 i was doing
things i wasn't too proud of you know
and one of those things was robbing drug
dealers or trying to [__] be a thief
i don't know why i don't know where it
came from
and one night i was home and i watched
the movie thief i watched the first time
thief came out
was in 1979 1980 and it won the cons
film festival
and i still remember the commercial for
it but i was going through so much with
my mother's death and whatnot that i
never got to see it fast forward to
[__] 1981
[Music]
hbo had
the raging bull
thief
and [__] hollywood nights on
this one hbo didn't have 10 million
movies
hbo maybe had you know 20 movies they'd
run 10 of them monday night 10 of them
tuesday night then wednesday night
they'd run 10 more i don't know if
that's what they did
but i could call my brother mike and we
watched the raging bull and [__]
thief every night for probably three
months we would walk the path mark
shoplift ice cream to make protein
shakes and [__] coke cuts and we'd be
home by one and we watched the thief
hollywood nights and [__] uh and the
real thing about hollywood nights was
you ready for this
you know who's in hollywood knights mike
binder who is the director of the comedy
store documentary
mike binder first time i saw mike binder
was in hollywood knights and i realized
that they had a couple comics on that
and years later i watched it again and
half the comedy store
is in that [__] movie except for fran
dreschler
fran dressler's in that i think it's
michelle pfeiffer no no no yeah yeah
michelle pfeiffer's in hollywood nights
with tony [__] danza jack guys
i'm a movie buff i'm trying to tell you
this [__] you know some dear dad was at
a party and somebody was talking about
the pilot that spread the aids
and also and i go
the band
moves on or whatever the [__] name of
that movie was if you've never seen that
movie on hbo as a matter of fact guys
i've been doing the album of the week
on patreon
i don't know if i'm gonna switch it i
think i'm gonna give him a different
surprise every week i think i'm gonna go
from the movie of the week to the album
of the week because i can't get albums
fast enough anymore you know all the i
just found the new [__] uh metal
place
keyport
how far is keyport new jersey from me
they got a metal something i gotta call
jimmy florentine later i just saw it on
facebook
like last week that they do having a
sale so maybe i could go down there
maybe i'll take a ride down to barnes
noble and try to pick up a [__] great
album that they have down there in
freehold but my album
my albums
have slowed down blah blah lingus thank
god bob just sent me a great [__]
album that i put on it's a quiet riot a
[__] album i don't know where he got
it from bob but bob always comes through
i got to call him up and thank him for
that one but yeah man although
that cinema was a big part of my life
and now that i don't have it
i've tried to do it like i've tried to
go on movie theaters and go down to
freehold and it's
it's a [__] you know 12 pier theater
and people walk it's not the same guys
i'm talking about a movie theater an old
fashioned
one movie movie theater
that's it i know there's still one in
fair view fairview cinema had one of the
best ones i ever went to why because
they had a midnight showing
they had midnight movies the first
saturday and friday of the month
tremendous that's add that too that's
what i want to do and all and guys
listen it sucked because it was the same
10 movies that they played at midnight
it was just so remains the same
pink floyd live from pompeii
neil uh crosby stills nation young had a
concert movie
yeah yeah that's
we [__] guys the midnight movies were
a blast plus
the midnight movie we went to had two
movie theaters they had the rocky horror
picture show
and they had whatever you were playing
like throughout the week that's the same
movie theater i went to see apocalypse
now at
that's the same movie theater i went to
see uh
i went to see a couple things at the
fairview cinema
the [__] one night i went to the fair
like this is what i'm talking about like
a bunch of us got together and went to
the fairview cinema to watch
i don't know
[__] uh the crosby oh neil young had
neil young and crazy horse had a movie
uh who else had a concert film guys
there must have been 10 bands that had
him like five that you didn't want you
know the beatles had the yellow
submarine and help they played those two
or or [__] help they played at
midnight
they played all those type of films but
i still remember being out there and it
was a gigantic [__] line
and we're all the way in the [__]
back
but the thing the other reason i liked
about the fairview
cinema the double feature was that 50
yards away there was a carvel
so we would go up there go to carvel and
then walk the [__] guys i'm telling
there's always a carvel and we would
walk back to the fairview cinema and one
day
we're online and we're all the way in
the [__] back and we had this crazy
kid with me john crowley
and i'm like how the [__] are we going
to cut in the line i'm like john you got
to do something to get us in the line
and john looked up and right when you
walked in there was an ice cream cone
that somebody was eating
but they got into the movie theater so
they threw the ice cream cone on the
floor and there was ants on the ice
cream but the cone was still intact and
it was just melted this [__]
picked it up with the ants and started
eating the ice cream and everybody was
like oh
so we cut right in that line while
they're moving back we cut right in the
[__] line
and got back there i mean this is this
was this is what we did as kids and i'll
never forget being in the movie theater
with like 20 gorillas
and people were just yelling and
screaming before the movie starts you're
like before they even put the upcoming
events and all of a sudden somebody goes
crowley get up there and talk to these
people
and john walked up to the front of the
movie theater
and he just [__] unloaded a bunch of
jokes and people were booing at him like
boo boo we're [__] howling in the
back and finally some guy goes shut the
[__] up let them talk that's the guy
that ate the ice cream outside with the
ants on it
and they were like okay let them talk
and [__] another time i went in there my
friend was high as [__] he didn't like
long-head people and he walked into the
rocky heart picture show by mistake
and we're sitting outside and also here
[__] you i'll knock you all out he's
[__] fighting like three other people
in costume and [__] you can't write that
stuff guys you can't you gotta live it
you know what i'm saying that's the same
that we're watching the story remains
the same
and he came into the movie thing i had a
buddy lebrano that stuttered he started
all the time and [__] we're watching
it we're watching robin playing he's
like
you know he always does that and no no
no no and my friend would go libretto
and the movie theater in yellow after
like the third lebron people like shot
the [__] up with lebron up cuz he kept
saying librato because robert plant
started so
this was
who the [__] has these stories in the
movie theater you know what i'm saying
like we think we used to go to peep
shows and then go to a movie theater
like we were like in the 8th grade me
and my buddies would go to peep shows in
42nd street then the movie theater and
then go back to the peep show and then
the way home stop on 42nd street and buy
an id a fake id can you deal with that
one [__] no that's how we were living
back here [__] so
yeah that was a long [__] time ago
but that's why i'm so emotional
about theater and the movies the [__]
movies that coming out which suck
including mine how's that one for you
when somebody tells you that movies suck
at least they're honest with you
like i don't even want to do a movie
anymore because i'm sick and tired of
being in bad [__] movies
i love spiderman too because i can walk
around my [__] head up like yeah it
did 60 million you know what i'm saying
the longest yard did 60 million then
everything else i've been in has been a
[__] bomb i'm heartbroken i'm [__]
heartbroken even the kevin hart storm
movie made 20 million dollars christmas
day i was like
what i don't even think i get residuals
on that movie anymore people just
stopped watching and they got kevin
[__] heart in it kevin [__] heart
de niro
[__] stallone and the movie i get
like seven dollars a month from [__]
residuals nobody watches that movie so
i'm done
i'm [__] done every movie sucks
they just i don't know i don't know what
happened to the writing in films
i mean i think the last really good
movie to come out from my taste
was men on fire
equalize was okay
equalizer too
okay
everything else i've seen has been
acceptable
not really
you know what i'm saying but the last
good movie i saw
was 2004.
i think
man on fire came out january
of 2004 and it made like
30 million dollars at the movie theater
then it went away it disappeared
did not january of 2004
i did not see that movie
in the movie theater i'd love to tell
you i knew about it
but just to let you know how
[__] much i loved movies and how much
i enjoyed my process
when i got locked up
the the same [__] librarian that told
me to get into comedy he would stab me
or shoot me
gave me a book like my second month
there when i got to prison i was reading
a lot
i read like [__] uh
cujo i [__] love cujo
you know that's a great stephen king
book i read uh the biography of the
[__] guy from texas that
the president the guy that ran for
president no no the guy that ran for
president
and he [__] lost but he's a
billionaire he's [__] ross perot i
love [__] ross pearl
and uh i just read a couple books and i
i went and asked him one day he got a
book for me to read and he goes yeah i'm
going to give you this book called
wiseguy
and i'll never forget wise guy and i
[__] read the book and it was about
henry hill
henry hill and paulie and henry uh
paulie's son and all this [__] so i'm
pretty [__] excited it's a pretty
goddamn good book
and then he turned me on and then he
goes hey man tonight on 2020
they're gonna interview
henry hill or somebody from that book
you know and
i remember going to his room me him told
ray piles a bunch of us and we watched
the [__] henry hill interview about
him
uh going into restaurants and shaking
them down how they did it and stuff like
that you know
remember the goodfellas and they go in
and they shake the restaurant down
you know uh how they would go to you go
to a club a bunch or not like you go to
a restaurant every night for about two
months you pay cash you pay cash cash
cash buy him a drink buy him a drink buy
him a drink and after about two months
one day you call mike come here for a
second i left my wallet at home do you
mind if i
uh eat here tonight might say sure you
spend [__] two thousand here at night
what that guy put on me i'll give you a
tab sign it and you got a tab and what
they would do is they run up the tabs
and then they wait for you to come to
them and go hey mike you owe me
20 grand on the tab
then you're like you [__] [__] sucker
after all i do for you in this [__]
restaurant you're gonna embarrass me for
twenty thousand dollars and i go to
swing at you but one of the guys holds
me back it's all set up
and the next day somebody slips the guy
a call card and says mike if you want to
squash this deal with joey call this guy
and you call that guy and the guy will
say come down they'll go listen what
we'll do is this will pay the twenty
thousand dollars but why don't you make
us a partner and this [__] won't happen
and then they'll put rival crews to go
in there and do the same thing
so you want this to stop
you want to stop listen make me a
partner
you get your deliveries on time the
garbage will get picked up on time you
know and nobody will do this to you and
then that's where the good fellas they
bust out a joint and they take it out so
he told that story on that somebody
something else
and i'll never forget
i don't even know
i'd like to tell you that i read it i
don't even know i found out in a [__]
obscure way that
goodfellas was wise guy i'll never
forget that was like three weeks out
guys i've always been pretty excited for
upcoming movies when i know about the
movie like the last 20 years no but when
i was younger like i knew about 48 hours
i still remember going to see 40 hours
with my buddies and [__] it was the
coldest night ever in new jersey we went
to see it at edgewater while we were
sitting in the car smoking pot the rats
were under the car scratching at us and
[__]
you have no [__] idea but
goodfellas like i really wanted to see
it and i was not going to see it on a
friday night when goodfellas got
released i was in the halfway house i
was in the bctc in boulder
and i was like you know you can't smoke
pot when you're in a halfway house so i
was like how am i gonna do my [__]
my system because i remember when i was
in the halfway house my escape was
my escape has always been the movies i
still remember going to see turner and
hooch by myself with tom hanks i'll tell
you about movies i went to see i'm not
embarrassed about them i like all
different types of movies i remember
going to see batman by myself with jack
nicholson
and all those movies i used to go to all
that when i was in the halfway house and
that was great
jurassic park but
when goodfellas came up i didn't give a
[__] whether i peed in the bottle
i didn't give a [__] but i was in jail i
was doing my system i'll never forget
when goodfellas [__] came out i was
in the halfway house and you weren't
allowed to drive
unless you get to like level four and
then you're allowed to level fours when
you could take furloughs
stay out till midnight and you could
drive
i was like level three
so i was not allowed to drive and i'll
never forget i go i'm going to see good
fellas so what i did was i got a i told
them i worked at a
at a detailing shop and i did i worked
for my buddy but they couldn't call the
shop i was always on the pager
so they would never know where i was
and then i worked driving cars so they
could never really
arrest me
or
press charges on me for driving a car so
i'll never forget i'm [__] i'm
counting the minutes to this [__]
goodfellas right
it's uh
maybe 1990 it came out 1990 i'm counting
the [__] minutes what when was it it
premiered in september except yeah that
makes sense i'm 90. yeah it makes sense
that was close to my
separation so i could i
i was miserable i was [__] miserable
in september 1990 i was in the halfway
house
i think i was married yeah i was married
i was not [__] happy
i'm like i'll find a little refuge by
going to see goodfellas so i went i got
some reefer
and i'm driving to the [__] movie
theater and who pulls up next to me but
my counselor
and she's next to me at the light
smoking a cigarette and i'm right next
to her going holy [__] please don't look
over at me and i couldn't move the car
back or forward because then she'd
really look i'd get her attract
attention
so i was like [__] this i just sat there
and the light turned green and she
didn't see me i was like
i [__] went there that's when you
what i was doing in those days was i was
almost i was almost level four anyway
so what i was doing those days was i
would roll a joint i would roll a
regular joint not a big joint not a
little joint i just broke a relative
regular joke joint and i had a gym i had
a gym i paid 35 bucks for it was a
garage i had a punching bag weights a
radio and i would leave that joint in
the gym because nobody knew i had that
gym only my wife knew i had that gym
nobody knew i had that [__] gym so i
would go there i would leave a joint and
all my reefer and cocaine and everything
i would leave there when i was in the
halfway house i had a scale in there i
had everything in there but i would go
in there and i'd
roll a tiny joint and this is what i
would do
and i'd turn it up and that was it that
was the extent of my smoke and that
joint would last me two [__] months
but i would get so high on those two
[__] hits
i would get so high because that's all
the body i trained my body just to live
off hits
one hit
and i would get stoned i would go for my
chinese food then i'd take two more hits
to follow the [__] uh
program and i went to see [__] good
fellas i didn't give a [__]
if they were gonna throw me in jail i
didn't give a [__] about the the blood
test the piss test they never piss test
me they never did anything so
here i am so obviously i beat it but
if there's one thing in this life right
now that i [__] truly miss
and there's one thing i really enjoyed
growing up and i still do
and you know people tell you oh it's
great i could watch a movie at home i'll
tell you what it's not bad watching a
movie you know it's not bad
but it's not a [__] movie theater
it's not a movie theater guys it just
sucks it did
the
that's why i called it the cinematic
experience it's not just going to the
movies yes there's some people who go to
the movies i was never one of them
for me it was an experience for me it
was
two or three hours like i could go to a
matinee and go
like mike with congo what time do you
want to meet today for
mike i'm going a [__] 11 30 movie if
rambo 2 is good i'm gonna stay in there
and watch it again i would just get up
and go to the other side of the feed i
just get up go to the bathroom
make a call on the pay phone make
believe and the guy would go for
something i'd sneak right back into the
[__] theater i did not care that was
my life i was such and i miss it i
[__] miss that
so [__] much well i missed i'll tell
you what else happened
doing movies and working on movies and
being in that industry it's like looking
behind the curtain and you're like well
like the other i was watching spider-man
2 with my daughter and he's on the
[__] train with the thing i still
remember them shooting at
i still remember them shooting it and
there was nothing what you guys think
he was on a train
right they had him they had ropes around
his arm like jesus christ
to [__] give like the web effect just
to so he wouldn't fall off the train
i don't know how they were doing it they
gave him
movement in his arms and he was on a
train the train was standing still
the train was standing still
i didn't see the cgi going past they
don't show that in the studio all they
showed was the camera on him
and right there where mike is where the
camera is right there there's the
biggest [__] fan you've ever seen in
your life and i'm not talking about a
fan this bait i'm talking about the fan
the size of this room guys it's you know
it's probably i don't know 10 feet in
[__] diameter from one point to the
other diameter is the circumference of
it i mean just it's a big [__] fan
and they would have that fan maybe 20
yards away from him
and that fan would just be [__]
blowing on him and he would have to they
put something in his eyes which you
don't see
yeah they did a bunch of [__] i watched
those scenes getting i love all guys
it's my [__] world hot
the only reason why i didn't become a
director
or a [__] movie maker was because
to be a director guys you got to [__]
put your time in
you got to put your [__] time in
you know we live in la we live in a time
now where everybody wants to be a
director because everybody has a [__]
camera
but nobody knows how to [__] direct
movies no more at all not really good
directors
you see the finished product
first of all the product doesn't end
with the director no more it ends with
the studio
the director shoots and they pick the
[__] thing and they put it in
the director
i like i like particular directors when
i like particular guys i'm such a movie
buff
like rick ramos i got to have rick ramos
back on here rick's in arizona i haven't
spoken to him in like [__] three
months he's living with his mom he's got
a job but he's still doing the podcast
and stuff but even
rick and i would talk for hours about
movies and experiences and movie
theaters i tell you why i went to a
movie theater once i was kick-ass
[__] toronto
toronto had a kick-ass movie experience
guys in
1997. i can't imagine what they're doing
now they had an experience with that
waiters waitresses your feet went up
little table next to you they they
weren't one more than all these gnc
what's the name of the movie theater amc
like amc they all have the seats and
that's great they had the recliner with
the table next to you
[__] weight you could press a button
and a waitress came to you from matinee
movies and [__]
i love all that [__] so that is my
[__] bucket list
i'm happy i [__] said it out loud
today i'm getting old
i don't want to do half the [__] i was
doing i'll tell you what happened today
tell you what happened monday morning so
over the weekend i booked a couple more
dates i booked
the 7th and 8th at uh uncle vinnie's
because the residency starts on the 17th
and i want to be ready to rock
so i was trying to book uh
a couple of rooms around the area like
i'm going to do it tripoli's coming i
think is it this weekend
next weekend sam triple will be
at the [__] uh
a dojo of comedy we'll i'll come up
there one night
and do a guest set with him in fact i'll
call him today and try to book a
wednesday there
i try to book him
is he yeah so it's just friday right
yeah so this fri and friday and saturday
or just friday
saturday
okay
yeah so friday and saturday sam triple
is at the go the
a comedy both nights friday and saturday
so i'll probably go out there and see
him saturday night and [__] around with
him a little
say hello but i called the comedy club i
had my you know i called the guy and i'm
like i meant i want to work your club he
goes what date and i go july 21st you
know it's thursday night
i'm at the uncle vinnie's on the
20th so i want to do one week where i do
two nights i don't want to do friday and
saturday though i got too many things
going on the weekends
so uh
the guy goes i'll call you back i'm
having lunch okay and
he called back like three hours later i
was busy doing something
i went to the [__] uh marlboro
fourth of july thing on sunday
yeah yeah that's what i was doing i went
to the fourth of july they had like a on
the tenth they had it because
everybody's away for the fourth of july
they did fireworks in the band and they
had ice creams and [__] so he called me
when i was there so i didn't want to
[__] the music was on i couldn't hear
over the music
so
uh
monday morning tuesday morning i wake up
and
i got a message from my agent he goes
yeah he agreed to do the thing but
he agreed to this this and this but he
wants you to pay
500 dollars for [__]
advertising i'm like
no that you know that's what they do to
you
these nothing not the comedy clubs as
much but theaters always have like you
know for uh expenses what are the
[__] expenses
give me the expenses let me know what
the expenses are maybe get them cheaper
you know saying so when you ask them
what the expenses are they start [__]
dwindling so i said listen i'm not
giving you 500 per expense it's a
one-night show
this is what i'm doing this is what i'm
taking i'm charging 25 tickets you know
i'm not raping anybody i'm i'm not you
know that's not my [__] whatever so
yeah he wanted 500 bucks for me to do
the show i'm like
see you later bye
i could just keep going uncle vinnie's
or
the dojo economy or whatever the [__] i
want i don't need to go to your [__]
room for 500 [__] dollars so
like i said to you guys i you know and i
had to call the guy and go listen forget
my agent i'm going to tell you how it is
last time i worked your room you had
[__] people standing there
you those people paid and you didn't pay
me from what they paid i let that go
but if i go there again and i see a
person standing up or anything i'm just
walking off the [__] stage
like
i don't need to do this i don't need to
do stand-up right now i'm doing it just
as a hobby for me but once they start
[__] around me again i will not like
these people i told my agent i go cancel
a gig cancel the deal withdraw the
author really come on oh
sorry now you know your [__] job next
time too
now you know what needs to be done
because i told you [__] i'm not
[__] around with these people no more
i didn't listen up for 10 years it's my
game now or we're not [__] doing it
you know when you when you're a chief of
police or when you're doing when you're
on the job for 20 [__] years or
something like that you get to pick your
[__] schedule
get to pick your schedule now it's my
time to pick my [__] schedule i don't
want to waste my time on friday and
[__] saturdays i got [__] going on
i'll come in on a wednesday or thursday
but it's an isolated night and i don't
want to hear none of your [__]
thievery [__] like that that [__] does
not work for me
yeah
yeah i promote my own dates 1 500
[__] dollars so now you see what the
[__] i deal with anyway i love you
[__] with all my heart sorry
about not having a guest today you guys
don't want one anyway
i love [__] cinema old school just
going to a movie theater by myself
i don't want to know about arcs and [__]
like that i just want to have a good
time and be entertained guys that's it i
love you [__] with all my heart
thank you for watching remember we got
the 20th to july and uncles
august 3rd and august 10th i don't
[__] know go to uncle vinnies.com and
take a look and then we got uh
that's it i wish i had more to [__]
tell you [__] do not forget
july 16th
[__] tremendous on the gaffing
laughing gas label and that's it and
that's that i love you [__]
with all my heart have a great week and
i'll see you [__] monday morning
tip
top magoo i'm gonna have a tremendous
jiu jitsu guy on next week to talk about
the commitment of being a world champion
i love you stay black
all right we talked about cinema now you
know what [__] the movies were like
to experience but that's it
the joint is brought to you by
factor listen
you want to relax in the summer you
don't want to be cooking and cutting
[__] and washing dishes
fact that has tons of balance and
delicious meals and add-ons smoothies
shakes snacks and anything in between
factor makes it easy to eat well for
breakfast lunch dinner
they're fresh never frozen meals that
are delicious and nutritious new gourmet
plus meals make it eating at home feels
extra special for an additional cost
these meals are prepared to perfection
by factor chef and ready to eat in
record time don't spend your after work
hours in the grocery store waiting
online you got to bring your own bag
forget that
go to factor75.com
dot
factor75.com joey120
again use
codejoey120 to receive 120 000 discounts
listen they offer vegan
veggie meals keto meals calorie smart
options cold pressed juices smoothies
energy bites
you name it
they got that factor 75.com
slash joy 120
to save you 120
the joint is also brought to you by
liquid iv listen when it comes to
dehydration these [__] are
tremendous one stick of liquid iv in 16
ounces of water hydrates you two times
faster than water alone
concord grape pina colada
tropical punch the [__] cherry is out
of this mind i love them you can use
these first things in the morning before
a workout you feel run down when you
wake up after a long night you're out
there eating ass and [__] drinking
this is the way to go the single serve
packaging helps you stay hydrated while
on the go or on the road i love liquid
iv it contains five vitamins b3
5 6 12 and vitamin c and it contains
three times the electrolytes of those
shitty sports drinks
liquid iv is made with premium
ingredients and free of gluten
dairy and soy so grab your liquid iv in
bulk at costco but guess what
if you go to the website with uncle joey
i'm going to save you 25
at liquid
iv.com that's 25 percent at
liquidity.com 25 off anything you order
to help you stay hydrated today by using
joey
liquidity.com again that's
tickledyev.com
use code joey and the joint is also
brought to you by cbd line
when it comes to cbd why would i hang
out with a company this long if they
weren't superior to all the other
[__] maggots out there
go to cbd lion read the third party lab
results
and see why they're number one uncle
joey's [__] world
and with that i want to thank liquid iv
factor and cbd lion but most importantly
i want to thank you [__] savages have
a great weekend
stay black and uncle joey loves you
[Music]
so
you